hey welcome to day three of our little
trip here today is the camo day so I am
sporting the finest camo you guys might
remember I got this in Miami like last
year day 4 day 4 camo the finest I don't
want to film me because your your boobs
might be showing B is for Bruce boobs so
we're gonna we want to do this little
thing actually it's not that little it's
a big rap that they pull you oh my god
that looks like so much fun I'm losing
my mind just thinking about it probably
gonna get a concussion
I'm concussed just thinking about it we
have to do it
how do we do it okay we had a quick
wardrobe change we're gonna only be
taking GoPros leaving all of our stuff
here so hopefully I don't lose my GoPro
I'll be very very very sad time is now
[Music]
we will
whoa
[Music]
you
I can't even tell you how insane that
thing was that ride I can't even talk I
hate looking at my arm okay just let me
put you in the middle there like just
here's the thickest of the of the three
and we blood pick a step them all we put
Bree in the mid oh great job this is
really pretty